Roland Emmerich's Midway is a historical war
movie that has audiences shaking their heads,
with plenty of things that just seem too insane
to be true.
But sometimes reality really is stranger than
fiction.
Here are the things in Midway you won't believe
were true.
"This is actually what happened."
Most of Midway's characters are based on real
people, including Nick Jonas's Bruno Gaido.
Remember that unlikely scene where the USS
Enterprise is raided by Japanese bombers,
only to have them all miss... except for one,
badly damaged, about to crash into the ship?
Gaido hops into a nearby dive bomber and starts
shooting, only to send the bomber careening
away at the last minute, at the same time
the plane he's in takes a direct hit.
Surely Hollywood drama, right?
It's absolutely true.
Gaido really did take a running leap into
a parked plane, then opened fire on a Japanese
bomber intent on crashing into the Enterprise,
just like the movie depicts.
The Japanese bomber really did clip Gaido's
plane, slicing off the tail and sending it
skidding across the deck.
"Too much excitement for you?"
There is a tad bit of creative license that
was taken.
In the aftermath of the real incident, Gaido
extinguished a gasoline fire and then disappeared.
He had been afraid he was going to get reprimanded
for leaving his watch position, but instead,
he was found, taken in front of Admiral Halsey,
and promoted on the spot just like the film
shows.
Even the bravest military is going to fail
without reliable weapons and equipment, and
that makes it all the more shocking that Midway
suggests the Pacific front was fighting with
torpedoes that didn't exactly work.
The film makes several mentions of torpedoes
not being tested or reliable, and even showing
one scoring a direct hit only to break apart
and sink.
Unlikely-sounding?
Yes.
True?
Also yes.
In real life, the Mark 14 Torpedo was reportedly
pretty much useless, with a tendency to just...
not explode after colliding with its target.
And the military knew it, sending the torpedoes
into combat even though they had around a
50 percent failure rate.
Just a few months after Pearl Harbor, that
failure rate had increased to around 80 percent.
Midway is a visually stunning movie that puts
audiences right in the cockpit of World War
II dive-bombers.
It seems insane that pilots would literally
dive through a rain of fire to try and sink
massive ships but they did.
The Douglas SBD Dauntless dive-bomber was
the plane known as "Slow But Deadly."
They were flying at a time when aircraft were
still pretty bare-bones, and in the mid-1930s,
both the Navy and the Marines were beginning
to appreciate the death-defying practice of
dive-bombing as the best way to accurately
aim, and they built aircraft suited to the
task.
The Dauntless had things like split flaps
and dive brakes, and allowed pilots to dive
at an 80-degree angle at speeds nearing 300
mph.
They turned the tide at Midway, when taking
advantage of a sky momentarily clear of Japanese
counter-attacks Commander Clarence McClusky
led just a handful of dive-bombers against
the Japanese fleet, mortally damaging three
of the four carriers in around five minutes.
The Doolittle Raid is treated as something
of an aside in Midway, a daring mission happening
alongside the main action.
We see Jimmy Doolittle and his men heading
out to launch some serious retaliation on
Tokyo, with no guarantees that they're carrying
enough fuel to get them to safety.
Aaron Eckhart's Doolittle makes it into Japanese-held
China and meets up with allies happy to see
the Americans who struck a blow to their oppressors.
Again, absolutely true.
The mission was reportedly so secret that
President Franklin Roosevelt wasn't even initially
informed about it.
The plan was to take off around 300 miles
from Japan's shores, but as in the film they
were forced to take off much earlier.
The fleet was spotted when they were 700 miles
out, and the early launch may have saved the
mission.
Japanese commanders knew the short range of
American fighters and weren't expecting a
long-range launch and weren't ready for it.
It's an odd little detail, at first.
Midway's Admiral Halsey, played by Dennis
Quaid, complains of a rash that quickly gets
worse.Halsey is ordered to step down and head
to the hospital.
Even those with a passing knowledge of World
War II's Pacific Theater have heard of Rear
Admiral William F. "Bull" Halsey, so... what
gives?
Was he really sidelined by a rash?
Yes.
According to the US Naval Institute, it was
just one of a handful of incidents where illness
impacted command.
That rash was a severe case of psoriasis,
and it was so bad it was interfering with
his ability to make decisions.
The biggest change the movie made was making
it a symptom of shingles, which is contagious,
maybe making his absence seem more justifiable
to an audience.
Wouldn't want to put other people at risk
on the battlefield, after all.
When audiences see the USS Yorktown after
the Battle of Coral Sea, she's in a dismal
state.
She's in dry dock, gaping holes in her deck,
with crews that are dwarfed by the sheer size
of the damage they're trying to fix.
But in the film, she's back on the water and
sailing in to save the day just hours afterwards.
Unlikely?
Yes.
But also true.
According to the US Navy, the Yorktown returned
to Pearl Harbor with an open hull, leaking
oil, and sporting enough damage that it was
estimated it would be 90 days before she was
operational again.
A 551-pound bomb had sliced through the deck
and detonated 50 feet into the ship.
Her hull was cracked, elevators non-functional,
and she had left 10 miles of oil and fuel
in her wake.
When she returned to Pearl Harbor, plans for
Midway were already underway.
Admiral Nimitz gave them three days to get
the Yorktown back in the water ... and they
did it.
Around 1,400 workers labored for 72 hours
straight on repairs that were so intensive
the island was subjected to a series of blackouts
to funnel electricity to the repair docks.
In Midway, American planes have a crucial
advantage: time, chaos, and confusion stemming
from an armaments change-over by the Japanese
military.
And that happened.
According to the Smithsonian, the Japanese
air fleet was originally equipped with torpedoes,
geared for fighting American carriers.
Vice Admiral Chuichi Nagumo gave the order
to have everything re-equipped for an attack
on Midway, and that meant swapping torpedoes
for bombs.
The switch was in mid-completion when they
got word American ships had been spotted by
scouts, and suddenly that meant they needed
to swap back to torpedoes again.
What followed was more than chaos: Japanese
aircraft were slow to get into the air, and
ordnance was left scattered across the decks
of the carriers.
All that ordnance was highly explosive, and
added fuel to the fire American dive-bombers
started dropping.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.